so let's start by first explaining what
is a blockchain
well a blockchain is just a data
structure that basically provides the
capabilities of a ledger so the
properties of a blockchain are
essentially three-fold the first one is
it provides this mechanism called
consensus which means that all the
participants in the system agree on what
data lives on the blockchain
unfortunately there's a bit of a caveat
to that and the caveat is that in fact
they agree on everything that's on the
blockchain except perhaps the last most
recent few entries that were added to
the chain
the second property is what we call
consent what we call persistence and
persistence basically means that once
data has been added to the blockchain it
can never be removed yeah and this is
kind of an extremely important property
of a blockchain once data has been added
there is no way to take it off
now again there's a caveat to that as
well
so this is a star star property that
basically says that in fact persistence
will only hold as long as we make
certain assumptions about the adversary
for example maybe the adversary only has
limited computing power
the third property that a blockchain
provides is what we call liveness which
means that in fact anyone can add data
to the blockchain so it's not possible
to prevent you from adding your own
transactions to the blockchain or it's
not possible for the blockchain to get
stuck so that no one can add new
transactions to it okay so i want you to
remember these three properties
consensus persistence and liveness
because those are going to be kind of
fundamental properties that the
blockchain as a data structure provides
to us and we're going to be building
applications on top of that i should
mention by the way if you want to see a
more formal definition of what a
blockchain is there's this nice paper
from 2016 that you can take a look at
and there's a much deeper analysis of
what a blockchain is and how do we argue
that consensus protocols actually
provide these these capabilities
okay so now that we understand what a
blockchain is
let's look at kind of the first
application for a blockchain which is a
currency yeah so how is the how does a
blockchain
provide a currency
well essentially as i said the fact that
we have consensus means that everybody
agrees on the set of transactions that
were already executed which means that
everybody agrees on how much money
everybody has yeah so all the
participants in the system sort of agree
on the current state of the world in
particular how much every participant
actually owns
persistence in the contents of a
currency means that once a transaction
has been executed there's no way to
revert that transaction yeah so in some
sense that's something that you often
want of the currency system in once in
the sense that once i pay you there's no
way for me to take the money back
yeah maybe you can give me the money
back but uh
as a change to the system there's no way
for me to kind of undo a transaction
that was already made
and liveness is kind of the the third
property which basically means the
system cannot get stuck and all of a
sudden not accept any more transactions
and moreover if a user uh wants to uh
submit a transaction to the system that
he will always have the ability to do it
so no one can prevent you from spending
the money that you already know own okay
so you can see how these properties of
consensus persistence and liveness um
immediately translates to providing a
currency and we'll talk more about that
later on but you already see why these
kind of properties are kind of
interesting on their own right
okay
so now the question is how do we achieve
persistence
persistence is kind of a difficult
property to achieve in a computer system
because a computer system can always be
snapshotted and then after some
modifications have been made to the
state of the system you can always
revert back back to the original
snapshot position yeah and that would
kind of undo everything that was done
after the snapshot was taken so the
question is how do we achieve
persistence in a computing computing
environment and the answer is basically
persistence is achieved by replication
across many many different parties so in
fact the blockchain as a whole is
replicated across many players so for
example miners are the ones who write
new data to the blockchain but in
addition they also uh store the entire
history of the blockchain locally okay
so the entire blockchain is replicated
to all the miners in the system the
people who write data to the blockchain
uh end users will monitor the blockchain
the blockchain for data that affects
themselves so for example if we're
implementing a currency um an end user
might want to know how much money do i
currently have in this currency and to
do that they will monitor the blockchain
by replicating it and
[Music]
looking at how much money they actually
have
so again there are ways to make this
more efficient uh but overall end user
there are end users who actually
replicate the blockchain
and there are particular software
applications often called wallets that
actually can be used to say how much how
much money each user has again uh there
are wallets that don't need to replicate
the entire blockchain but at the same
time
there are definitely users who do
replicate the the entirety of it and
then there are service providers who do
analysis of the blockchain like just
understanding the rate of transactions
understanding different aspects of the
blockchain and again they replicate the
blockchain
in order to process it okay so the fact
that this data is replicated across so
many participants makes it very
difficult to revert to an old state
because essentially you would have to
rever revert
all the participants who have
replicated the data on their own
so yeah so the fact is the fact that
everything is replicated means everyone
can validate that all transactions uh in
fact were done correctly on the
blockchain uh and in fact if ever if
ever we find a transaction that's
invalid the block that contains that
transaction is simply gonna be dropped
yeah so there's no incentive to creating
um an invalid transaction because anyone
who validates it will just ignore it and
it's not going to propagate throughout
the system and again we'll see more of
that in just a little bit
yeah and the point is that uh consensus
means essentially everybody's looking at
the same data and because they've all
validated it we know that it's the same
valid data so everybody agrees on the
state of the blockchain uh and all and
presumably all the transactions that are
on the blockchain are all valid under
the rules of the blockchain protocol